what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you know i had to publish this for like
25 minutes and uh i fired her after she
uh two weeks after i uh did rogue and
she texted me she went you did rogan so
like that all right i gotta go i said
let's go yeah also she asked me to uh uh
her ex-boyfriend who had blocked her on
facebook she wanted me to go and look
what relationship status he was in so i
said she might not be the most
professional in this
oh yeah this is a real problem and she's
charging you real fees like you're
charging me money and i and i so i had
to say no to her and uh but she said she
goes i'm gonna try to get you like uh
this was a fact she was trying to get me
like like she wanted mega bus
to endorse me because this was like when
i used to take mega buses to shows like
not currently but like i had a bit about
it my act like mega best so she goes
we'd like you know i i would love you
know we'd love to get together mega
busters
in business explain megabus to people
megabus is just it's the bus that passes
you buy and it goes for a dollar get on
yeah and it's it's never a dollar but
it's always like it's right as the buses
go it's a pretty good option it's like a
double decker it's college kids old
people
you know hippies it's not that bad it's
not like greyhound and then it starts to
fall off a little bit it gets really bad
uh lucky star like they get real bad
they get bad they get bad but megabus
was one that i would take a lot and she
goes she goes i i she goes i said this
was her quote she goes it'll be great to
get you in business with a brand like
megabus
so
i'm still open to that i'm still what
was your response to that great
because that's what this business does
to you you're like absolutely
i will advertise anything wait a minute
this is a joke
when i was 19 i used to go around with a
slingshot my boy had a slingshot we
would go we would break bus terminal
windows on francis lewis boulevard and
we would just [ __ ] shatter bus
terminal windows if i was a lot if i was
a 19 year old kid right now i'd be at
the protest to [ __ ] break in windows
of police presence when i was 19 i was
[ __ ] lending [ __ ] janitors eight
hundred thousand dollars to buy their
dream home on long island and now
they're dead in the streets
so who cares so if i come to you right
now let's go back you're you're a
mortgage broker in long island i meet
you in a diner which is you call your
office the imperial diner of freeport
absolutely phenomenal yeah you got to
make it real yeah so it's the imperial
diner in freeport on merrickrobe
yeah you say meet me at the office and
you i hear you hey i will spill hot
coffee in here but i mistake it looking
and go yeah yeah and when you tell me to
meet you at your office i hear the clang
of a pay phone when you hang up yeah and
so i meet your office i come in i say
hey how you doing nice to meet you mr
dylan me and my wife just got married um
you know i'm a comedian i i saved up
about 80k
um uh you know she wants to live we're
having a baby
i'm very glad can i get a loan not only
can you get a loan but let me let me
tell you something yeah how much that
80k are you prepared to spend on the
property
i don't know uh mr dillon i you know i'm
pretty conservative guys saved every
single dollar from my mother's house
how much you prepared to spend um
hold on let me go into maurice's no no
of that 80 000 how much would you like
to spend are you willing to spend all of
that i'm going to spend i'm willing to
spend about 60 or 70 of it mr pappas
guess how much of that 80 you're gonna
have to spend how much nothing
what nothing you're not going to spend
anything because let me explain
something to you sit down the wife is
lovely would you like a cup of coffee
yeah here's the thing
i get pancakes yeah you can get anything
the bricks and sticks of your house yeah
appreciate
the frame
the land
they appreciate value you know what your
money does in your house for you mr
pappas it does absolutely nothing you
know what the wealthiest people do with
real estate mr pappas a lot of them
finance it why because your mortgage is
your only tax write-off it is the only
write-off is your only [ __ ] weapon
against the federal government the
larger the loan you take the better it
is for you financially and you take that
eighty thousand dollars and i'm not
wrong by the way and you put while i'm a
little and you put it in tax exempt
securities like roth iras mr pappas you
maximize the amount of of tax exempt
retirement accounts that you put your
money in with that 80 000 you make it
work for you you do not sync it into a
house yes or yes so the reality is this
we're taking the biggest loan possible
debt mr pappas will set you free
now sign this piece of paper for christ
at that point you and your wife are
crying yeah yeah and then we signed
papers then you go die but how do you
get the loan from the bank
they're giving them away
what are we doing we're talking about
now or back in the day back in the day
yeah better gonna go to bank i said
kelly we got one and kelly i said mr
pappas and his wife brittany's from long
island they want to go buy a piece of
marble hunk of [ __ ]
and kelly has got coke running down her
nose from last night she's got a [ __ ]
double tall non-fat latte from starbucks
non-fat she's not getting anyone
and she knows it down and she says let
me
she makes all the paperwork look like it
should look and then my little shitty
bank which was called franklin first or
new world mortgage or the mortgage zone
or if the funding hot or whatever it is
we send our paper
to a [ __ ] even bigger and as
similarly shitty bank like a long beach
mortgage or a new century mortgage or an
argent and those banks were doing back
door deals with jp morgan city group so
those banks were underwriting the paper
to the to the middle grade banks that
were lending money to the dirt bed
brokerage operating out of a van places
that i worked
okay right so when this all
you ever played a game hot potato yeah
it's an orgy yeah so when so when
everything goes wrong you pass it around
we're passing around and by the time you
sign your mortgage by the time you get
your first bill because the other
benefit mr pop is you don't pay for two
months right for two months you don't
pay but are you sure i'm going to be
able to afford this mortgage my stand-up
comedy career is up and down mr pappas i
have watched your stuff i think you're a
genius thank you
you think i'm leaving tick tock
no
i've enjoyed all the friendships thanks
for turning the volume up
background some dramas going on
no
really
really i didn't even know you were
allowed to be on i don't even have books
i didn't know you were allowed to be on
it if you were over 19.
like i had no idea that there were 60
year olds leaving tick tock oh there are
like emotions making an announcement
you're like emotionally going i have
made a lot of friendships here it's like
that's illegal
it's against the law what do you think
you've made a lot of friendships here
right what are you talking about i mean
we had been day drinking in florida yeah
my family
and we saw these little kids like fifth
graders yeah um
by the pool and this place and uh
we walked in on them and they were
choreographed we were like what are you
doing and we've been drinking right and
they're like oh and they're in their
school uniforms they're like we're
making a tick tock and we both were like
we're on tick tock and
and uh they were like oh okay these are
like 10 11 year old girls they're gonna
get kidnapped and then they're like
what's your handle and i was like i've
spelled it out for them and then as we
walked out i realized that the last one
i had posted was me pulling my nipples
and going
like that
but i was like oh we gotta go we gotta
we gotta get out of here
you know
i mean yeah it's one of those things man
it's like old people have facebook
that's where you go yeah that's where
you go to scream into the void talk
about your new operation yes talk about
donald trump talk about dead animals
talking around the end of the voice i
mean that's what it is that's what
you're there that's what it's for
amazing a backyard show amazing all
right i just want it it'll be my first
be great it'll be fun as soon as you get
that laugh and you're in you're like oh
i'm back in and it's amazing um but then
staying they're closing all the parking
garages in new york now at midnight
because homeless people i guess are just
walking down into them and they're like
hey this is a fun cave yeah yeah
what could happen here yeah
i like cars yeah yeah
you know like i imagine like homeless
people like there's a there's a a cave
full of luxury cars two blocks away yeah
we don't have to be in the rain tonight
right
and so they are
closing those at midnight so that me and
my my uh opener we get back and we're
driving around the city trying to find a
spot
everything's just weird man we went into
a bodega at like one
we're like standing there there's a
homeless woman in there
begging for tea
the dude's like it's your third tee
and then you're looking at two guys that
are kind of walking around the bodega
and you're like
something feels off like are they about
to whip a gun out am i just paranoid
because of the news
nobody's out at night new york city used
to be and i lived there for years
bumping dude bumping 3 a.m i mean i'm
being a diner yelling at people yeah how
[ __ ] this business was you know i have
been denied the amount
of bitter resentful bile that came out
of my mouth
as marinara sauce was flying out of it
mozzarella stick by just being like the
denial this [ __ ] that's a special um
just nasty
real horror i wasted so much in new york
like i loved it it was amazing yeah but
like uh just the amount of time i spent
walking around being angry yeah and not
in awe of what an amazing city it was
like my opener
he he paints this picture of like it's
so amazing he's like it's just so easy
to meet girls and you're dating and it's
just you're there you guys can go get
margaritas and i'm like but what about
the all the hatred like didn't you just
walk around
every day
consumed with a darkness in you you
didn't know how to get rid of
he's like well not really no
he's like i was dating and i'm like but
what about the late nights on the roof
of your building smoking a cigarette
cursing god
because and it so i but i i love it
there
i miss it a little never lived there
again uh because me and new york have
that relationship where we destroy each
other
um
i was a tour guide i ruined people's
lives i ruined vacations that people had
saved up their entire life to come to
new york to just see it and i would grab
the microphone and i'd go this city
sucks and i am dying in this city
i have nothing and everyone i know has
nothing
everyone i said i know some of the most
talented people and they're getting
nowhere and people were like this is
really we just want to see the lion king
we just want to see the lion were you
doing bus tours yeah double decker bus
stores i would stand on the bus and i
would just go out there and i would tell
people i would say
they'd be like it seems like you have
such a fun job i say ask winter
you know how many how many operations
winter's had on her foot
six
she's had six foot operations she's 68
years old okay she doesn't want to show
you carnegie hall anymore she wants the
long sleep like it was such
it was bad
tour guides are tragic characters you
become a tourist in your own home you
start falling in love with the buildings
you hate people yeah you hate people so
that was my experience in new york was
just an orb of negativity
a broken ankle
last night last night she said i had an
overwhelming amount of pressure there
was no real sickness it was just an
overwhelming amount of pressure that
needed to be released the worst part is
the video she's like don't worry i'll
relieve you from the pressure and mike's
like
yes thank you nurse yeah
no idea it's like someone's holding a
gun to his head yeah role-play
you have to get you have to get better
at it yes you have to get better you
ever do the rpg stuff the role-playing
well that's yeah i think everyone
rpg in the night room i think when
someone's hooking up with me they're
always pretending i'm someone else so i
always imagine they're doing a role play
in their head
um because their eyes are closed and a
lot of times they're screaming uh no
i've never i'm not into like role
playing i think it's just hot enough
from like i'm me you're you
that's
that's good enough
this is fun enough and i'm also bad like
i would want to be something that i i'm
believably not what for example
you know i just want to be i'd want to
be a sport like in sports or a fight
like it would be ridiculous
yeah i'm like a fighter i'd be like i'm
a boxer and you're and they go no you're
not you're not
no so i want i'll do like a realistic
role play where i'm like a manager
at a burger king yeah at a
at an island's burgers and shakes i'm a
manager restaurant great great and i'm a
manager and you're a waiter who's gonna
be fired and uh you know and it's just
very and it's always sexual harass all
my role plays are oh i'm committing a
felony right in my head so that's why i
stay away from it because i'm like oh
this is an abuse of power this is not
good so i try to just stay away look tim
joe rogan says you're a national
treasure he also said the vaccine for
coronavirus was freshly fallen snow
so i love him to death but you know he
says a lot yo he really he really he
really does he also said connecticut he
also said connecticut is simply a
highway between
new york every other day he talks like
vitamin d just go fit i'm like
i don't know but all right so i'm just
taking vitamin d no mask thinking i'm
good so i'm gonna drop dead on his
advice i love him to death by uh here's
a guy obviously he's looking to date
this guy looks like he's in trouble
it kind of looks like he didn't answer a
contact racing call
he's infected 38 people
hey uh mr dillon uh
huge fan mr vaughn long time
long time listener watcher first time
caller and communicator pardon my back
mullet
i don't have a top mullet but i got a
little back hair i'm gonna let that heat
go anyway i got a crazy question for mr
dylan what do you think about the
assassin
killing himself
that shot the judge's son
this jazlyn maxwell shit's getting a
little trash yes real creepy
yeah so let's get into that first let's
just establish that epstein you believe
epstein was a pedophile
i'm just saying let's just establish
some ground what are you working for
wait a minute hold on what
you just feel the pressure because
they're looking at other people in their
orbit and they're like yeah okay and
it's like the greta thundberg girl
um there's people that are like she's so
great but they're also on private jets
like these are people that take private
chats and they're like this girl's great
listen she made some valid points but
she was a little creepy it was a creepy
speech i don't know if you saw it
unfortunately i don't know how much we
could tell i've watched it five to five
times it was it was too much you know so
so the the the normal reaction that from
a human being that just turned on their
tv was like what
like yeah okay but is she okay like that
was a normal reaction like what's going
on she's like my childhood you're like
this is this is very odd you know
i wanted her to go the full thing and
just start throwing out conspiracies you
know you killed jeffrey
in the cell
and then you come to us
and ask us it's like wait a minute okay
now it's getting good some are saying
she's like a pl
like a plant of some man i don't listen
here's the deal others are saying that
she's actually
i did a video on on on instagram and i
put it out on twitter when i have to
cook i just did an i pretended to be an
agent for like these kids and it was
just wasn't making fun of these kids
which is making fun of agents yeah like
the idea that you'd be an agent for a
child activist you know and you just
represented all these people it's like
can you get david hogg on the phone we
sent 30 pairs of sneakers to his dorm
you know i need this guy you know this
is his agent who was like malala went
with a competitor you haven't heard her
name in two years then it was like
malala you got to come out as non-binary
if you want heat now no one cares about
land mines honey nobody gives a [ __ ]
about clean water it's about guns and
climate you know so there are people
behind these doesn't mean the kids are
wrong there's people behind them there's
a machine it's the way it is do they
build them or do they see opportunities
and then promote them i don't think
anybody needs to get built i think
people show up it's like listen people
get cast think about it like a movie
right people get cast in a role but they
how many people show up wanting the role
uh and and it was just this really
depressing time
and i
you know it was you know the saddest you
know sales guys are supposed to have
money confidence yeah we had none of
that left we've been broken beaten down
and broken um and the dude who was kind
of the head of the operation was just
drunk named bob bob had lost
bob had lost his license for dewey so we
had to take turns driving him home he
was our boss
everyone yeah yeah yeah and when he you
have to drive your butt and you would
fall asleep because you'd drink all day
at chili's and then he'd fall asleep uh
on the way home in your car and then
wake up
like at a stoplight to just deliver a
cryptic message like he'd be like
and they were like we're in big trouble
i'll tell you that much
and you go what and then he goes no no
[ __ ] left at park avenue
so he would just deliver his cryptic
messages
this is how that company started you
want to hear how this that company start
i pitched this as a show and nobody
bought it are they [ __ ] not sickler
yeah so here's what happened this is how
the company started this guy bob was a
high level guy and a major mortgage
lender in long island he's a cfo he sees
that this company is going to kind of
crumble he sees the writing on the wall
it's like we're in trouble we're holding
on to a lot of bad debt this thing's
just going to go it's going left we got
to get out so he pulls his buddy his
buddy and him instead of evacuating the
business right this is such a long
island [ __ ] thing they go we're going
to do it the right way
we have all this know-how we're going to
put together a small company we're going
to do it the right way
so they go up to this guy's house
upstate which is partially done they're
getting sauced they're talking about the
new company they're gonna have whoever
this other guy is i don't know
falls through
a second floor that's not completely
done and dies no
die come on while they're up there
talking about this correct
instead of abandoning the project bob
then walks around at his funeral and
goes i just want to let you know i'm
going to open the company for your
father
he was a good man he believed in tight
lending standards we're going to open
this company
the underwriting it was cr
and he started in death yeah it started
in death
and i worked there for about a year and
a half um
very sad christmas party
very very soft yeah very sad it's just
that like most outdoor things
are
not brand new they're not ideal
here's the thing though when i went and
did the uh uh outdoor shows with cars
it was very weird for the first like
five minutes it was like they're honking
i was dr i was like this is awful i hate
it i don't wanna
five minutes in i was [ __ ] like i get
it okay i know but we have evolved it's
called podcasting i don't want to
perform for cars i can just be funny for
an hour or two hours a week well your
fan base doesn't have to work
so i'm sorry my fan base isn't my other
celebrity friends
i apologize you know i apologize
jennifer aniston and sandra who are
these people it's over
it's over ladies and gentlemen is tick
tock real yeah benton makes a very good
point
people have eight million followers on
tick tock
the same person will have like a hundred
thousand on instagram what's happening
because everybody on instagram is an old
witch like your friends
and on tick tock everybody's just hot as
[ __ ] and we don't care
and we don't care about old people and
what they're about like we're about
positivity and light
and and showing and being healthy and
showing our on showing our our dicks
that's what we're about so i'm not
i'm not upset at old school people what
is the most important platform right now
according to you
most realtors are brain dead and and
they they're amassed these large
fortunes by being brain and it's like
it's the funniest because none of the
interactions are real like none of the
like they're all like he's like you want
it for eight but it's gonna be for you
know we're too far apart it's really
like nine but like you know a lot of
those real conversations are like a
realtor turning around and going listen
be like my client's trying to get out of
china with his life right now you know
you know the world bank you know this
guy they want him for genocide he
poisoned a river
but he loves this infinity pool he's
gonna get his money out here but you
gotta listen i mean this guy i mean he's
a they want him for narco trafficking
he's
this is the sinaloa cartel let's make a
deal yeah let's go you know you need and
instead it's like i like the windows
it's like that's not it no that isn't it
definitely this guy is killed
fights oh yeah in new york he wants this
apartment like all the people that own
these houses are like fertile russian
fertilizer magnets oh yeah chinese
amusement park tycoons yeah yeah oh yeah
now i bet you were a [ __ ] savage uh
what did you do subprime mortgage i was
i sold sell prime mortgages because i
believe in people and their ability to
oh no
that's number one that's number one and
i i would stop from doing that by a
totalitarian government who does not
believe in people the way that i do so
sorry would you tell people who were
like i don't know if i can afford this
you're like dude by the way i'm looking
at america is a country of thieves and
criminals yeah no one said i don't think
i can afford i love true by the way i
love that that's such an innocent great
way to think about it yeah like there's
someone on the phone where i'm like hey
we could get you 300 grand thursday and
then go like this i don't know if i can
afford it no it's america everyone's a
derby they're like i can't they're like
can we get it tuesday yeah can we get it
when you make it 500 yeah so it's
actually not i mean i'm sure the
predatory landing went on things like
that went on but the majority of people
that i worked with were
uh selfish yeah scoundrels yeah that
wanted money where you ever gave them
money did you i bought a subprime more i
bought a house with a stop right more
you did yeah did you ever get to the
like did you ever have somebody whatever
who's i don't know the ins and outs of
it but applying and you looked at their
stuff you're like there's no way we can
give this guy anything well the worst
one we had was a guy who was clearly
like had dementia or didn't know where
he was and his son wanted to open up a
strip club in miami and his son just
took all the money out of his house and
we were sitting at the closing
and we're signing papers this old guy's
like struggling to sign papers and his
son is like keep signing daddy it's
almost over and the closing attorney
said i'm not really comfortable with
this and i'm like yeah it ain't great
but
you know
i mean at that point you know what are
you gonna do yeah
yeah shout out to the vasquez um
but there again it's a guy that came to
me he's like my father's you know an old
guy i want to suck all the money out of
his house yeah and go up into a strip
club it's like all right how's that
strip club doing you know i don't know
tom but
if i was a bet man yeah you know i don't
know i bet that's a great business i
think it really does i love sales i miss
it and i just i love it i love her i
love sitting in a room with uneducated
people
calling people over the phone and trying
to build an empire
there's many like they're gonna be
closed down they were cool
like they were cool in the sense that
you could walk by you see like live
octopus and stuff down in chinatown now
i think that's over i actually think
chinatown in new york city is going to
you know sadly it's they're going to
have their they are going to have a long
hard road back yep because not only
those markets probably going to have to
close but then i think a lot of people's
people just going to be nervous about
going down there and look i i that's
true i i think that you know a lot i
don't think it's time yet to go like
what are all the like silver linings
coming out of this right i'm seeing a
lot of rich hollywood people be like but
it's so good for the environment like
okay yes but not yet like we're yeah
like
everyone's like this dolphins are back
in the canals in venice and it's like
that's great my grandmother's burning
50.
you know we can't hold a funeral for my
uncle
oh where are the swans where are the oh
the swans are back in venice a lot of
people are going back to their
grassroots of foods i'm finding you know
theo you struggle a little bit with a
little
little
in england they call them a [ __ ]
the cigarettes brendan yeah
yeah the last [ __ ] i'm dealing with is in
this room and it ain't you timmy i'll
tell you that
hey thank you so much here's what i'm
saying is i don't even know what i'm
[ __ ] saying dude what is this native
american asking about
what's up gang listen all right i have a
king in this thing for y'all okay
so doing my job
shout out the oven in asphalt but doing
my job i travel a lot
um
and with that i miss out on a lot of
family time a lot of
you know friend time
people that i know clothes you know that
living back at home and i don't get to
spend any time with them and i know you
guys deal with the same [ __ ]
being that you guys go on the road and
do shows and it usually works out
because it's better pay right so that's
my question is it better just to stay
home find work and just struggle if you
have to or is it better
to travel miss out on family time but
get better pay
um
yeah get gang buzz buzz [ __ ]
play boys
let's talk
with brendan here because brendan's
missed half of his children's life to be
[ __ ] performing in boise next week so
what do you say brendan yeah that's true
yeah the pandemic made me realize i tore
too much man so i cut it down to two
weekends a month moving forward i just
do three to four right so i cut it down
to two so i'm around my kids more
but theo you don't have to i mean you
just own a [ __ ] backpack so you can
tour all year long
yeah that's true man you're right i
think what this guy is saying is first
of all i like where this guy is at this
is the kind of guy you need help with we
don't need to be storming a capital we
need a storm at t we need a storm
[ __ ] right dunkin donuts headquarters
we need a storm zabara we need to store
tech is the new fossil fuels guys okay
and so we need to be storming places
that it hits him in the wallet
now this guy's question is should he
look at work or raise his family oh yeah
my bad sorry i kind of diverted what do
you say that's his question should he
work or raise his family yeah well i
would think that he could maybe both
yes
i mean that might be a good idea like
this guy i think i think he wants us to
co-sign his decision of like just
abandoning his family
so he could [ __ ] pick cell phone
towers i'm like
dude you gotta check in on the fam every
now and then you know
yeah maybe i'm chilling the craziest
it's the craziest question i've ever
heard he's like
hey guys uh
i i work a lot and i travel i wanna know
do i still have to talk to my family
it's like yeah i'm putting up all these
5g towers man i haven't seen my son in
three years yeah do i technically have
to like see and speak to my family i
mean i have a job i have a job why would
i
yeah dude do balls yeah
that's not a bad thought that's a decent
suggestion tim tim also i just realized
looks like the poseidon of [ __ ] key
west florida right now let me tell you
right now there's no place i'd rather be
sitting there
uh uh eating a conch fritter uh drinking
it don julio blanco white tequila on the
rocks
and uh just sitting there and uh talking
about a marina that i wish i had the
balls to burn down because they [ __ ]
me over on a boat slip
literally where i want to be i would
turn to somebody i'd be smoking a
cigarette and i'd be like they gave the
last slip away i said if i was more of a
man i'd go down and i'd burn that
[ __ ] thing down myself
sometimes you
we we
people are in pain all over the place
right we know that oh but there's also a
lot of there listen
there was a lot of fun
in that in that crack
there were a lot of
positive people
i mean i know i mean genuinely positive
i know you mean
genuinely like genuinely grateful
and positive people like there were
people there that if you gave them a
cigarette would act like you paid for
their college
so to me it's like how bad can it be
like
they they were so
i just remember how happy if you gave
someone a cigarette they would be
happy
and it's like i know people with oodles
of money and fame that just can't figure
out how to be happy yes i will take a
controversial stance because i believe
epstein is a pedophile okay you heard it
here okay and you think geez lane was
his little his uh
his his runner yeah i think that's
pretty well established i think miss
maxwell was involved in some alert and
inappropriate activities but as trump
would say i wish her well yeah because
that's the way rich people talk rich
people every now and then rich people
just become rich and they forget that
they have a job he forgot he was the
president yeah he was at a golf tee on
mar-a-lago in his mind and he he said
what he would have said to some ceo that
was next to me yeah i was sure well wow
that looks like the 3 500 cubic foot to
the first air conditioner i send i'm
de-platformed like right afterwards and
i call mike i go dude what happened i
just sent an air conditioner it was like
a dual meaning
you know who got halsey pregnant
i don't
either
who is it are you saying it's are you
saying it's me
drop in the air
we've [ __ ]
a lot
a lot because i like her the whiny
nature of her whatever she does and uh
but i'm dating billy eilish
oh how's that how's that going where's
your legal name she's illegal yeah uh
how is it it's very sad
she's very moody a little emo for my
taste it's a little sad and a little
vegan for my lacking where'd you meet um
uh where did we meet i i was i don't
know some seance i don't know what she
does uh have you seen the documentary
about her the documentary about is like
a horror movie where it's like it's like
and she's clearly very talented but like
the doc that's coming out about her now
it's like this horrific why i don't know
i'm like everything's okay
you're doing well it's like that dixie
million girls that song sometimes i
don't want to be happy it's like no
you're gonna be happy
and you're gonna be [ __ ] happy now
800 000 people a week are filing for
unemployment you're singing in a mansion
you're gonna be happy or we're gonna
throw you in a volcano
i'm sorry but that we've i don't care
well money doesn't make you hap shut up
like you can't release a song during a
pandemic and an economic collapse and go
sometimes i don't want to be happy it's
like you gotta you gotta be happy it's
relatable bieber dropped lonely because
you have you guys and then you have
people you have like the people that eat
cereal
you have the mukbang people you're the
people that open presents i mean i think
there is a prop like it is a problem
like i look at what's on youtube and i'm
like this is not good like i see
somebody opening a present there's 30
million people that are like i wish i
had a presence i'm like how bad is it
out there i watched a new documentary on
influencers uh it was on hulu it was
called jawline and all these girls you
know the magcon guys like all the girls
that were going to see them i thought
these girls just thought they were hot
but a lot of these girls it was so sad
they're like my mother works three jobs
i don't have a father these are the only
people that tell me not to kill myself
and i'm like oh my i was like so sad i'm
like i had no idea how bad it was
out there i thought you just wanted to
you thought they were cute no taylor
knife is these girls role models i
thought they thought he was cute they're
like they're the only people that say
don't cut yourself go to school i'm like
what is going on so i don't know man
it's a i think it's
it's there's a lot of trouble we're in
trouble as a country yeah i mean we're
in some trouble is it just the country
or is it the world
no it's everything it's the whole planet
you know but i mean i get a view of this
country but yeah the youtube thing
uh there's like girls that are 800
pounds me and ben the other day my
producer just watched a a very large
woman eat a whole chicken
bones and all right
with the bones great question how many
views
hundreds of thousands she's just a very
large woman eating all chicken i just
try to understand like what is what's
going on what's wrong with us
something's wrong dude are we [ __ ] i
don't know but it it it it ain't great
and if you go on youtube
it's not great a part of that or ever
will be or and that's i need not even
say that but i i just it's not an area
that i'm not going to be kept up at
night by bay ridge but i'm not kept up
at night by where i grew up right where
do you want to where what keeps you up
at night
yeah yeah fifth avenue park avenue yeah
yeah
is that the bronx compared to no i mean
beverly hills yeah i mean in in terms of
taste yes but there's some real money
over there yeah there's some real money
over there uh you know pollock's path in
hong kong yeah keeps me up one hyde park
in london yeah those just see it's
interesting i just like to know you know
i said to ben my producer we were eating
he's on the hot seat yeah he's on hot
seat better he better figure it out yeah
almost pimp's coming pimp's coming i'm
gonna take pimp and i'm not gonna pay
you but you're going to meet whitney
cummings so the whole thing is you're
going to inject both talk to the whitney
coming's ass here's the whole thing and
it's better than money
so the reaction we're gonna we're gonna
release this so we gotta i don't care
she doesn't care she's a comic
okay she's the only comic in l.a right
now not in jail rfp here's the point
this is what i'm saying
uh what i'm saying is that he needs to
uh yeah i have that wheelchair plug but
i think it's closer to sarasota i gotta
hit him back up about i was supposed to
plug him up with that dub c over there
in tampa yeah dude your opener needs a
wheelchair no he did he wanted to go out
because he does
surgery he wanted people to wheel him
around the bars and then he got covered
because he's an idiot going out to bars
or whatever and i get it but it's three
three weeks he's still kind of tired and
listless and [ __ ]
you know but hey man that's what you get
that's what you get for not taking queer
seating which cures coronavirus
according to joe rogan i called the
doctor right after that and the doctor
said there is no evidence of that
[Laughter]
and he goes that is very damaging
information to spread so he goes i hope
you're not telling that to a lot of
people i'm like the guy who told me that
is telling two tops 10
million it's not a big deal
all right all right one more culture
corner submission god i love that guy
dude hajime nice it's japanese
what up king of distinct boy daniel and
i just want to say what's up to theo
brendan chappelle
cat
nick
chin
the dude that sits in the other studio
but never looks up at the camera like
it's the hot chick from junior high
school that i never even had the balls
to smile at
it's all called
oh yeah the culture corner
well my dad was born in mexico my
grandma barely spoke english i barely
speak spanish but somehow we make it
work if that's not the definition of
culture i don't know what is
i can already see myself in the culture
corner
if you guys choose me to sit on the same
couch that has grazed more butt cheeks
than george bush senior i'd be delighted
all i gotta say is gang gang
vatos locals forever
yeah that guy was great yeah he's really
good shout out to that dustin poirier
it's really good but it's boring
like i wanted to like him it's
mind-numbingly boring and i don't care
yeah i couldn't wait for it to end so if
he went to a hollywood meeting they'd go
like this they'd go hey thanks for
coming in
let us know what you're working on you
know
get the [ __ ] out cause that was boring
and a waste of everybody's goddamn
bring back that meth head [ __ ] tonto
or whatever
because that up this guy sucks why'd you
wait so long yeah yeah yeah or like
well it's also
ricky martin came out we were all like
what yeah yeah no one yeah how are you
the last to know about that yeah it's
also like um at this point it's not even
a thing like it's not a huge like we're
so past gay now yeah like we're past
trans even we're in like another
remember three weeks ago when we cared
about transgender yeah people in
libraries remember that it's like should
these drag queens be reading in the
library and now everybody's done
remember libraries yeah now everyone's
dead yeah it's well
but that stuff will come back you know
like that stuff will come back libraries
well no drag queens
the the the petty stuff comes back like
i love like after every tragedy
everybody
you know they have the same thing they
go you know what this is really going to
make us think about like
you know what's really important that's
what it's about and then two weeks after
it you're like i ordered the postmates
an hour ago so it's just the same thing
like i had this joke which never worked
it was right after the uh the mass
shooting in vegas and everyone's like
the most american people
were the people that you know risked
danger to help others and i was like no
the most american people were the people
that right after that shooting
walked down to the front desk to
complain about the noise
you know it was a little loud last night
you know maybe a coupon for lunch
you know we've been coming here a long
time and quite frankly a lot of sirens
you know i was like that's the most
american so we will go back to petty
we have to today's storyteller is a
return guest first time on video ladies
and gentlemen tim dillon's on oh thank
you so much thank you for coming back
look who's at your mom's house guys yeah
i did it i made it i made it to the
mecca officially interesting
it's i you know how can you enjoy me
without video you know
that says
translucent irish skin blister up in
real time in front of you how could you
possibly
but you you hear my voice and then you
hear the tragedy of what i'll say and
then i think the physical just brings it
all together it's where people go round
oh yeah
because that's what the show is right
you wanna you wanna hear sad things from
sad people
that make it funny i mean that's what
the show is it's an exercise in
masochism it is and you bring people on
and they talk about their horrible lives
and you know and some of the people you
have on are successful and some of the
people you have on it like me that are
just claw we're still clawing you know
clawing and it's not it's nice to watch
people
look at a lot of your guests and go will
they be
people that i know in five years or will
they be dead in the street
what i like about that's what this show
really is
people are going hey i wonder if that
guy will be a household name or will
they find him dead in a hotel room in
tampa we don't know who knows
who knows this is definitely
just what the show is
that's what the show is the best version
of the show
is let's bring these people on we don't
know if they're going to be successful
statistically it's a real uphill battle
and you know do you ever think that
they're do you ever meet women that are
close on a like there's almost like a
because sometimes i almost wonder if at
a certain point that gay and straight
will almost be primitive descriptions
like i know some of there's a lot of
force stuff and like you know and people
like in this place now where they don't
know or they you know and people are
just i think sex will be primitive i
think people are on so many ssris that
can't even come and i mean it can't get
dicks hard i mean just crazy you look at
a lot of these relationships you're like
there's no sex happening these people
just hold each other's hands they softly
cry they tweet about racism uh they
adopt a dog together uh but you you
really sexual a lot of these
relationships are you like a lot of this
is probably just people that have
massive anxiety laying next to each
other having multiple panic attacks and
then someone's strong enough to go make
a cup of like non-caffeinated tea but if
you ever yeah i'm during a tough panic
attack but it's almost that to move yeah
i think if kids are doing it when
they're little that's
that might be an issue because they
don't know yet right yeah if you're a
child age but i think if you're a parent
and you and you're going to allow your
eight-year-old to get a sex change
you'll have to get it too that's what i
would say you also
they will don't don't don't make that
the standard because they will they'll
get it because that's how psychotic yeah
because they'll be the most popular mom
and daughter i want to see you in
portland yeah i want to support
everything my little daughter is going
to do but i have to admit that will
be a little complicated and challenging
a little bit if if she starts saying
stop calling me gianna from now on i'm
g-dog yeah yeah i'm calling me g
they always start with an acronym
are you gonna name her what are you
gonna name her i'm gonna name her
gianna her name is gianna yeah her name
is gianna yeah
and uh i hope she's uh becomes g-dog
i hope she starts that'd be great
she's going to have a great life i'm
going to invite you guys up to the
compound right
she's going to sit on onky timmy's lap
uncle timmy's about going to tell her
about the ways of mortgaging in the
world yeah the first time you ever met
my daughter you have to sell her a pool
yeah
yeah he was like i got a beautiful and i
told her i see your father's making a
little coin but let's be honest you got
to start getting proactive with him
like start you know if you want to call
me a few of his bank out numbers let's
do some experiments it won't make him
happy yeah don't just make him money
like they were sitting there with elsie
and adults like that it was great but it
was either that or talked to uh uh who
who was at that party chris farley's
brother yeah i was like let's move on
[Applause]
i like kevin farley versus oh i like i
like i love
there's so many rats there now
everyone's always like what are you
doing instead a movie the point
wasn't exciting i guess what i'm
realizing about podcasting as i'm
talking to you is i'm kind of shy yeah
like i'm not this is like this is hard
for me to do right
it's difficult because you're i like
hiding behind a computer writing the
thing giving it and then doing the thing
after it's been practiced for a long
time well
for the every time i leave a podcast i
have a complete nervous breakdown i was
like that was terrible i'm quitting
podcasting for the no because you're
when you're authentic you're real
everyone loves you it's just like the
you listen everyone's got to get used to
it it's very different and i think that
like for the first half of your career
the movies were silent these were silent
films so you just had to look at someone
and they knew what you were talking
about you didn't have to learn dialogue
or anything and then when they started
doing color
they did color and you're like oh my god
i'm in color and then they did then they
did talking in the films dialogue you've
seen all of these advancements happening
now people have tvs in their home like
you saw people get tvs in their home in
the beginning you were on a show called
the shadow which was a radio show which
was one of the top radio shows
and they would interrupt it every now
and then when there was an announcement
about the war
but you've gone through all of these
things
and now you're like now you just have to
learn how to be yourself now now you're
just back
oh god what we're doing now is back to
the basics it really is like a different
world um from where
you know it was that i was kind of even
if you were out and comfortable and
everything back then it's still a
different world in these last 10 15.
yeah 100 so i would meet people but i
wasn't like introducing anyone to my
parents and then i came out at 25 to
your parents you're my parents yeah my
mom was like oh i would i thought i was
i want grandchildren and i'm like yeah
that's what you need i'm looking back in
the cage
[Laughter]
always like just make sure you you take
time to golf son you know or something
let's say just drop that in as long as
he just didn't have to work more hours i
don't think it bothered him we have a
gift for you oh my god we have a we have
a fan here oh wow uh uh no an actual fan
like a rotating yeah same place i bought
the air conditioner jake
jake bro do you have a gift
oh thank you okay we do have a gift
okay okay wait can you can we is there a
gun is this where i get killed yes
don't don't that's okay if it happens
like the joker fight for the
monetization
just just as a preface this dude has
watched everyone from mike tyson yeah to
every single person you know that's been
on the show walk into the show and he
messaged me today and he said you know
i'm hearing rumblings that tim dillon's
coming on the show i'm like yeah yeah
our homie timmy d he's been on before
like we're friends with the guys yeah
i have to i have to get him something i
have to get him a gift i'm like jake
what the [ __ ]
that's so sweet thank you so much
he lives in the studio it's also a
really strange gift before you leave l.a
dude i appreciate this so much it's just
an envelope so much oh it's a gift
certificate to craigs i [ __ ] love
craig thank you so much thank you so
much
i love this thank you dude i really
appreciate this and they just they just
opened restaurants no i i i appreciate
this and this is good yes outdoor the
amount of this is half of one appetizer
so i like i think that's very how much
how much i have to fit fifty dollars
yeah
at craigslist that's wonderful no i
appreciate it let's leave the kids i do
listen this is very nice i appreciate it
thank you so much he's sure he loves
craigslist he's short at gamestop i love
him lost everything
i'm like i'm like yeah it's not a lot
somebody goes he's homeless oh thank you
thank you so much because he lives in a
tent outside this house he's doing
something nice
i'm like well god dang no thank you dude
tim how are you feeling man now that do
you think it's a coincidence trump gets
banned from twitter and social media and
you get banned from airbnb i was banned
from airbnb i went to an airbnb in the
desert uh two uh lesbians had uh
you know uh put together an airbnb with
uh furniture that no one could sit on
right like art pieces like i had fat
people with me so they couldn't sit in
the chairs or anything we all had to
just stand out there in the middle of
the desert it was really embarrassing
and uh we left some dishes in the sink
that's all we did didn't break anything
i mean look at this look at that that's
what you had to sit on every piece of
furniture like sodomized you as you sat
on it like that's how [ __ ] up it was
look at that that's a chair it's
ridiculous
so then these lesbians uh i i threatened
to kill them i texted him i said i was
gonna burn down your house
they said are you threatening me i said
let's just see what happens uh i then
texted him i said let the games begin
ladies you have no idea who you're
[ __ ] with
then uh airbnb kicked me off
now did they file a formal complaint or
did everybody imagine you i i i i
followed the story i imagine these
because i spoke about it on my podcast
they said i wanted to gas them locked
them in their house
gassed them and watched them like like
paw at the windows like cats very much
like the patriot have you seen that
scene in the patriot yes that's what i
want
thank you yeah so that's where we're at
with that i am removed from airbnb but
uh i will set up my producer we'll just
set it up under his account and i'll use
vrbo i don't give a [ __ ] and uh you know
you're switching you know those ladies
you know watch your back
put your back have the fans been
harassing them do we know their profiles
and [ __ ] probably i don't know what my
fans i don't know what people do
i don't know if they're sending messages
but they had to go private on instagram
and they had to
uh you know turn off comments on the
page because they trashed me on a public
forum which is airbnb and i am just
using my opportunity as a citizen of
this country your voice to speak freely
against these two lesbians who
are not designers not artists not
interesting uh they are uh goofy [ __ ]
and you know we're locked in a war and
[ __ ] airbnb too and [ __ ] airbnb they're
not letting the terrorists stay in the
airbnbs they want to do the civil war
for the inauguration yeah [ __ ] that got
a king in or sing it or maybe even a rip
my drift for you you decide the 80s are
coming back that's why everyone's
rocking these ridiculous ass sunglasses
right so i got one for you brandon
you're all about that high fashion
that's why you stay rocking that romper
right so how you feel about dudes
bringing it back bringing back that
men's crop top
that half t-shirt hitter hit her baby
gang gang
buzz buzz
oh crop tops what do you think of this
man when you see this man what do you
think
that's not a gay man but he is sucks
dick for a gram of cocaine
so that is the perfect outfit on the
segway says hey i'm not gay but i will
suck in for coke in virginia beach so if
you're a businessman and you're at a
convention somewhere in virginia and
you're staying at a hotel and you find
yourself on a certain website at a
certain hour of night uh that guy's
showing up to your hotel room and uh
you're gonna get to suck this guy off
and you're gonna give him two hundred
dollars and he's gonna leave and he's
gonna go to [ __ ] uh waffle house and
just
[ __ ] live
that's exactly what that guy's life is
and by the way if it isn't it should be
and it's tragic
it's said or if he's not doing that
this guy will give you a [ __ ] with
his butthole i know that
i'm going to tell you speaking of wall
files i took my sister who hadn't seen
in a year and a half we met up at
walthouse over the holidays
and we sit in there we have some coffee
we finally order a woman comes over a
young woman of uh
different dialect maybe and she's like
we're like ordered
she's like can't you [ __ ] see the
chef quit a half hour ago we're like oh
[ __ ] oh no we can't
we didn't notice that it's christmas eve
we're sitting in here
and we're like well do you know when
she's gonna be actually like well
tiffany's outside of smoking and she
ain't [ __ ] happy right now
well we'll wait we'll wait so we waited
bro but
um anyway yeah this guy uh definitely
looks like um
post mates for his own
he looks like postmates for his own
semen that's what he looks like yeah
i mean this is the definition of if that
was your son oh dude if that was your
son
let me tell you right now
too if that was your son and you had to
look at that guy i'd rather him storm
the camera i mean the level of drunk you
would have to be
i mean just down syndrome drunk like
can't even feel your spine drunk
every time you see that man that guy at
thanksgiving
l5s what i don't know dude yeah i agree
with you man that guy look first of all
i think the guy's abused him like a nice
guy
um beautiful young guy you know
obviously
trying to get through college trying to
make it after college maybe yeah there's
no way i don't think so he's never gone
anywhere near a college uh just count
down the days of spring break yeah uh
maybe in best case he's in a technical
school by the side of a highway best
case he's learning to be an air
conditioning repairman at a technical
school which he hasn't showed up to in
two weeks and his mother has left cell
phone messages saying we're [ __ ]
paying for this we're paying for
brett
it
paying for this are you doing okay
this is the type of guy that disappears
for a year he he uploads song lyrics at
1am on facebook
then everyone's like oh he's in trouble
the comments on the page are like where
are you he disappears for a year and
then he re-emerges with a blurry photo
of himself standing on a hill and a
bible quote
that's who this guy is
[Laughter]
as a crystal ball at richard simmons
birthday party
that guy is not really doing too well
but he seems like a nice guy man and
look man we're happy he's getting a
video but
they send the video so we're kinging
crop tops it sounds like it's it's
stinky now that's a question
you think king of brandon no stink sting
no crop top we'll pick one man [ __ ]
pick one there's only two of them i said
sting bro
okay i thought you said king my bad man
these speakers are bad
uh let's see let's see what this guy has
to say
what up cats fam quick king of the
stinging for you
um ghosts at the comedy store i'm
currently watching
the ghost adventures episode when
they're at the comedy store so yeah um
you guys ever had anything happen to you
guys but
can you understand it
gang gang ghost ghost go on you guys go
first i i will say in terms of just
creepy things at the cops
i felt like a weird
like a banshee you know what a banshee
is yeah it's like an irish like i felt
like a weird like
feminine energy that was very like
chaotic and and bad and dark
and evil
uh that's coming down there's one guy
and it was it was whitney cummings
so that's
you got to be very careful
that's what i'm saying
um
[Music]
you